let's say you're trying to design some
type of a product for men one that is
somehow based on their height and the
product is for the United States so
ideally you would like to know the mean
height of men in the United States let
me write this down
mean height height of men men in the in
the United States so how would you do
that when I talk about the mean when I
talk about the mean I'm talking about
the arithmetic mean if I were to talk
about some other types of means and
there are other types of means like the
geometric mean I would specify it but
when people just say mean they're
usually talking about the arithmetic
mean so how would you go about finding
the mean height of men in the United
States
well the obvious one is as well you go
and you go and ask every or measure
every man in the United States take
their height add them all together
and then divide by the number of men
there are in the United States but the
question you need to ask yourself is
whether that is practical because you
have on the order let's see there's
about 300 million people in the United
States roughly half of them will be men
or at least they'll be male and so you
will have 150 million roughly 150
million men in the United States so if
you wanted the true mean height of all
of the men in the United States you
would have to somehow survey or not even
so you would have to be able to go and
measure all 150 million men and even if
you did try to do that by the time
you're done many many of them might have
passed away the new men will have been
born and so your data will go stale
immediately so it is seemingly
impossible or almost impossible to get
the exact height of every man in the
United States and a snapshot of time and
so well instead what you do is say well
look okay I can't get every man but
maybe I can take a sample I could take a
sample of the men in the United States
and I'm going to make an effort I'm
going to make an effort that it's a
random sample I don't want to just go
sample 100 people who happen to play
basketball or play basketball for their
college I don't want to go sample 100
people who are volleyball players
I want a randomly sample just you know
maybe the first person who comes out of
a mall in a random town or in several
towns or something like that something
that should not be based in any way or
skewed in any way by height so you take
a sample and from that sample you can
calculate a mean of at least the sample
and you'll hope that that is indicative
of if especially if this was a
reasonably random sample you'll hope
that that was indicative of the mean of
the entire population and what you're
going to see in much of statistics and
much of statistics it is all about
it is all about using using information
using things that we can calculate about
a sample to infer things about a
population because we can't directly
measure the entire population so for
example let's say and I wouldn't if
you're actually trying to do this I
would recommend doing at least 100 data
points or a thousand and later on we'll
talk about how you can think about
whether you've measured enough or how
confident you can be but let's just say
you're a little bit lazy and you just
sample you just sample five men and so
you get there five Heights let's say one
is 6.2 feet let's say one is 5.5 feet
5.5 feet would be five foot six inches
one would be let's say 1 ends up being
five point seven five seven five feet
another one is 6.3 feet another is 5.9
feet now if this is if these are the
ones that you happen to sample what
would you get what would you get for the
mean of this sample well let's get our
calculator out and we get six point two
plus five point five plus five point
seven five plus six point three plus
five point nine the sum is twenty nine
point six five and then we want to
divide by the number of data points we
have so we have five data points so
let's divide twenty nine point six five
divided by five
and we get 5.9 three feet so here our
sample mean and I'm going to denote it
with an X with a bar over it is and I
already forgot the number five point
nine three feet five point nine three
feet this is this is our sample sample
mean or if we want to make a clear
sample arithmetic mean and when we're
taking this calculation based on a
sample and then somehow we're trying to
estimate it for the entire population we
call this we call this right over here
we call it a statistic we call it a
statistic now you might be saying well
what what notation do we use if somehow
we are able to measure it for the
population let's say we can't even
measure it for the population but we at
least want to denote what the population
mean is well if you want to do that the
population mean is usually denoted by
the Greek letter mu so the population
mean is usually denoted by the Greek
letter mu and so a lot of statistics
it's calculating a sample mean and an
attempt to estimate this thing that you
might not know the population mean and
these calculations on the entire
population sometimes you might be able
to do it oftentimes you will not be able
to do it these are called parameters
this is called parameters so what you're
going to find in much of statistics it's
all about calculating statistics for a
sample finding these sample statistics
in order to estimate parameters for an
entire population now the last thing I
want to do is introduce you to some of
the notation that you might see in a
statistics textbook that looks very
mathy and very difficult but hopefully
after the next few minutes you'll
appreciate that it's really just doing
exactly what we did here adding up the
numbers and dividing by the number of
numbers you add if you had to do the
population mean it's the exact same
thing it's just many many more numbers
in this context you would have to add up
150 million numbers and divide by 150
million so how do mathematicians talk
about an operation like that adding up a
bunch of numbers and
dividing by the number of numbers well
let's first think about the sample mean
the sample will the sample mean because
that's where we actually did the
calculation so a mathematician might
call each of these data points they'll
call it let's say they'll call this
first one right over here they'll call
this X sub X sub one but call this one X
sub two the call this one X sub 3
they'll call this one when I say sub I'm
literally saying subscript 1 subscript 2
subscript 3 they could call this X
subscript 4 they could call this X
subscript 5 and so if you had n of these
you would just keep going X subscript 6x
scrub and X subscript 7 all the way to X
subscript n and so to take the sum of
all of these they would denote it as the
sum let me write it right over here so
they will say that the sample mean is
equal to the sum the sum of all my X sub
i's my X sub I so wait you can
conceptualize that these eyes will
change so the eyes are going to in this
case the I started at 1 the eyes are
going to start 1 until the size of our
actual sample so all the way until n in
this case n was equal to 5 so this is
literally saying this is really saying
this is equal to X sub 1 plus X sub 2
plus X sub 3 all the way all the way to
the nth one once again in this case we
only had 5 now are we done is this what
the sample mean is well no we aren't
done we can't we don't just add up all
of the all of the data points we then
have to add divide by the number of data
points there are so we then have to
divide we then have to divide by the
number of data points that there
actually are so this might look like
very fancy notation but it's really just
saying add up your data points and
divide by the number of data points you
have and this this this capital Greek
letter Sigma literally means sum sum all
of the X is from X sub 1 all the way to
X sub N and then
divided by the number of data points you
have now let's think about how we would
denote the same thing but instead of for
the sample mean doing it for the
population mean so the population mean
they will denote it with mu we already
talked about that and here once again
you're going to take the sum but this
time it's going to be the sum of all of
the elements in your population so your
X sub i's and you'll still start you'll
still start at I equals 1 but it usually
gets to noted that hey you're taking a
whole population so they'll often put a
capital n right over here to somehow to
note that this is a bigger number than
maybe this smaller n but once again we
are not done we have to divide by the
number of data points that we are
actually summing and so this once again
is the same thing as X sub 1 plus X sub
2 plus X sub 3 all the way to X sub
Capital n all of that divided all of
that divided by a capital N and once
again in this situation we found this
practical
we found this impractical we can debate
whether we took enough data points on
this on our sample mean right over here
but we're hoping that it's at least
somehow indicative of our population
mean